my first experience with the ocean
started out is a surfer I just loved
being in the water I love riding waves I
love the energy of the ocean and there
was no cost to entry to surfing you know
once I had a surfboard I could just ride
waves all day that love for the ocean
really started from from being in the
ocean but of course one thing leads to
another it became time to get a job and
when I wasn't good at unloading trucks
or other jobs I went back to what I
really love to do what I really love to
be in the ocean I looked at the list of
majors oceanography it just came out so
at first it was about finding the best
surf spots I would use my knowledge of
physical oceanography to find the best
way breaks and
and I kind of would look underneath my
board and I'd be like there's all these
animals down there and I started
freediving and that kind of just seeing
all the animals down there
kind of really turned me on just the
amount of my life then then I learned
how to scuba dive and one of the things
that I I guess I learned early is that
scuba diving at night was just
phenomenal because one not many
scientists or not many people go in the
ocean at night for me the ocean at night
just transforms into this whole other
universe and I like to go to places
where other people don't go so if
everybody's studying one thing that's
not what I'm gonna go and I'm not gonna
go study there I'm gonna go to the place
where no one's going and it didn't seem
like there was that many people studying
glowing animals at the bottom of the
ocean so that's where I went
[Music]